on the show i played a trivia game
called the balls of sports
which sounds gross against sports
broadcaster aaron andrews
and let's just say it didn't go swell in
what year did the atlanta braves most
recently win the world series oh my god
these are the hardest questions
that's a hard question right
94.96 it wasn't 94.
how do you know
incorrect the answer was 1995.
all right erin go ahead now it's your
turn you get you get to uh well i would
have to say volleyball but i'm going to
get it wrong because i don't know
anything about volleyball well then i
think you should pick volleyball
i think i win
that is correct look at that
unbelievable how does it feel
how's it feel kelly let me tell you hi
[Laughter]
and so my sister alisa and ali and
trisha
and ava were all here on zoom today to
figure out
what went wrong because we lost real big
to aaron andrews
and there were five of us and there was
one of her
so you know we're gonna figure out what
went wrong
[Music]
i know everyone wasn't too happy about
the way the game went so
i mean are you all just and you just all
think it's my fault is that what we're
saying
yeah i mean i love you
[Laughter]
i can't i know i've said this to each
and every one of you turds
i didn't remember we were playing
tic-tac-toe i thought it was
whoever knew the most sports launch we
got the most balls i thought it was
whoever got the most so i was trying to
well i did ask i said did they explain
to her
that they were playing tic-tac-toe they
did but then i forgot and all of a
sudden aaron anders was like i won i was
like girl there are so many balls up
there
she's so nice
tasty buttermilk breakfast entree
usually served with maple syrup
is also a volleyball move where a player
falls to the floor in an attempt to save
the ball
pancake that is correct
let me get to this though we started a
song with the football question
um but then i chose baseball and it went
downhill
uh the question was in what year did the
atlanta braves most recently win the
world series
um we guessed 1996 that's the royal week
because i wouldn't have even known a
decade
and the answer was 1995. now here's the
thing
i am personally disappointed in ava the
most because baseball is her
yeah not mine and trish and i both said
not
baseball here's the thing why didn't
y'all know that
no i knew that i slept in 2017.
who was the most mad that we lost i
would 100
trisha farrow
about a minute after we got done i
facetimed her and oh my god it was on
it was so hilarious it was like and i
said i told her i was like oh my god
it's
family feud and i put it in that text
that we whoever was in that
that tag not me y'all were talking about
just about me on that check
that's what's happening you don't know
how to play tickets
national television because you don't
know how to play tic-tac-toe
you know what i forgot that we were
playing
tic-tac-toe i don't know how else i can
say that i thought we were just trying
to get
all the balls the boxes many boxes
all right you know what listening to
direction i love my strong suit
it's just like family feudalism that's
exactly what trish and i said
amy schumer's brother did not get that
answer right
but i think that it would have gone
better if y'all are in studio if we do
this again
leads to my next question so do y'all
should just give me a little stink face
alex
y'all want another
[Laughter]
i am the lisa did you say i'm the mascot
[ __ ] i knew coach k i knew that answer
i knew
you did like what is that from duke
and he also
it's okay kelly two minutes into it i
realized too i was like oh wait you
can't answer all the questions
we're playing tic-tac-toe for two
minutes
i was like no no no tic-tac-toe
i was like why is she going to the top
right nowhere near where she was
no no we were playing tic-tac-toe i just
forgot i forgot
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do so much better
next time guys
i did apologize i said sorry i actually
didn't ever talk to ali i was afraid to
talk to ali
when they got the word every other
person i was like oh
didn't call me no
she wanted you to cool down i knew it
was well i knew i thought treasure might
have been the minute it's just because i
knew i saw her
i was saying she was like are you
serious we're on national television you
can't remember i played tic-tac-toe
the entire fourth floor knew i was bad i
know i forgot
i forgot and then yeah i didn't tell
alex i was like oh she was bummed we
were on national television i failed
her yeah i was like i was like
i'm gonna you know what guys i'm gonna
study up next time i didn't even study i
didn't do anything i didn't have it i
wasn't
all in i'm going to be all in next all
right directions
yeah read directions we're going to
listen to directions
all the directions mr allardyce
like you know what did y'all ever do
that did they ever trick you in class i
was one of the idiots
that they were like the second you know
if you read the directions say you don't
have to actually do this
yeah right yeah
oh i read the
um well i promise i'm gonna give us
another shot we're gonna do it
all right we'll bring bradshaw in here
yes
please oh my god i love him okay okay
we're not gonna love him in the moment
elisa we are gonna win
he's the end but i love him
[Laughter]
it's nice to see oh i got to go shoot
another show and like
that means i got to go back to work too
she has to go watch a kid i'm gonna go
cook dinner
you have to go help me
[Laughter]
i'll see you in an hour see you later
bye see you in a minute
bye love you luis love y'all bye bye
love you get out of this thing do you
just stop
oh my god please say someone was still
recording oh
god want more fun stuff i thought so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure